the eight assertive isms Darwinism the
philosopher Daniel Dennett described
Charles Darwin's theory of evolution
Darwinism as the single best idea anyone
has ever had it certainly was a
brilliant one though Darwin wasn't the
only ones come up with it
the naturist an explorer Alfred Russel
Wallace before the very similar
explanation of the biological data
independently of him at around the same
time but once Darwin published his book
on the origin of species in 1859 the
theory of evolution was ever after
linked with his name it was a radical
idea because although Darwin didn't
spell this out people soon realized it
entailed the view that human beings were
just another species in the animal
kingdom and shared a common ancestor
with apes for Victorian England this was
quite a bombshell as a young man Darwin
had spent five years as a naturist on
around the world trip aboard HMS Beagle
he'd gradually come to realize that
species change over time they evolved
imagine you're a Finch on a Galapagos
Island there are lots of plants with
seeds but not much else to eat your bill
is a good shape to cracking them open
lucky you that's probably just the
result of the variation that you find
within a species you happen to have a
beak that allows you to eat seeds others
aren't so fortunate you survive and
reproduce and pass that trait onto some
of your offspring the offspring that had
beaks like yours flourished the same
thing happens in the next generation
gradually over many thousands of years
the finches on this island that survived
become better adapted to the available
food stock your type of beak
predominates on another Island the main
diet is prickly pear and the finches
that survived and flourished there have
very different shape eats from yours
not only do members of a species change
as a result of such an evolution but
also entirely new species emerge today's
Darwinism is rather different from
Charles Darwin's Darwinism though we now
have a much better understanding of the
biology of heredity than he did
Darwinism today is a powerful
combination of Darwin's general theory
with modern genetics Darwinism is
central to understanding how we came to
be what we are
it's possibly the most important ISM yet
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon